Hello, and welcome to
"The Developer Show."
This is your TLDR.
Learn how to use the new
Save Data Client [INAUDIBLE]
to deliver fast and light
applications to users who
have opted into data savings.
It's available in Chrome,
Opera, and Yandex browsers,
and Ilya shows you how to use
it in the linked blog post.
The Google Cloud platform
now has their own podcast.
Tune in during your
commute, at the gym,
mowing the lawn, cooking
dinner, or wherever
to hear the exciting things
happening on Google Cloud.
Cross-platform
game publisher Poki
reaches 30 million
monthly active users,
and their recent mobile app
has over 500,000 downloads
and a 4.4 rating
across the app stores.
Check out the article for
tips from their co-founder
Sebastian on how they test
their games before launching.
We've made a number of
improvements in the Google Play
Developer Console to help
you engage and understand
your users with
ratings and reviews.
Updates include scene ratings
over time, ratings breakdown,
review highlights,
and device metadata.
The latest Android support
library is available now.
It adds a few new support
libraries as well as
new features to many of
the existing libraries.
The post has everything
you need to know.
If you watched last
week's show, you
know David East is always
ready to talk about Firebase.
And in this
interview, David talks
to Laurence Moroney
about what he calls
the holy grail of development.
It's probably something
that you should check out.
Google's Launchpad
Accelerator is a new program
that provides late-stage
startups with mentoring
and resources to successfully
scale in their local economies.
During the intensive
two-week Accelerator kick-off
in our Mountain
View headquarters
last month, Google engineers
from 11 product areas as well
as experts from other
companies were on hand
to provide 24 promising
startups with mentorship
on how to scale and
monetize their apps
and ultimately build
successful businesses.
Learn more on the post and
apply for the June class.
That's your "Developer
Show" for this week.
I'm recording
today on the ground
in Mountain View at the Women
Techmakers International
Women's Day event.
I'm getting some
great interviews,
packed with developer and
entrepreneurship tips.
Stay tuned for those coming
out over the next couple weeks,
and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel,
so you don't miss them.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next time.